foreign
so if you whack your thumb with a hammer
you think pain is in your thumb
Physicians have a more sophisticated
understanding we know that it's an alarm
that goes on nerves to your spine where
it is translated to your brain and pain
actually happens
somewhere it's a little vague we
actually only get two days of pain
education throughout all of medical
school so
in fact the only pain lecture I remember
from the 90s was in a dark room like
this after being awake for 30 hours and
hungry and finding out our noon lecture
was
sponsored by Oxycontin we got pens we
got great lasagna and they had very cool
slides that showed pain stopped by
opioids and we learned that home opioids
aren't addictive and if you stay ahead
of pain you can keep your patients
pain-free
and Beyond the obviously egregious
marketing I think it was framing
pain-free as the goal that has destroyed
countless lives
my friend's son Christopher started
having severe abdominal pain during this
no pain era
eventually he was diagnosed with a colon
disease and had surgery his senior year
they sent Christopher home with 90
Oxycontin
and then 90 more and then as the pain
started getting faster and faster
uncontrolled pain is terrifying so when
his ran out and his friend's medicine
cabinets ran out Christopher tried
heroin
and Christopher wolf lost his battle
with substance use at age 32.
so did we misunderstand pain
what if pain isn't an alarm to silence
but a learning system for survival
Ted pose
pain is every organism's Primary
Learning System for survival I mean it's
like ouch don't touch that or to
paraphrase The Princess Bride life is
pain highness
pain-free was marketing and it made
Physicians think that one pill could
solve pain it still makes people feel
like you can't be happy if you have some
pain and
we now know
that if you want to move past pain it
takes work
setting the bar of pain-free was too
high plenty of people could have been
more comfortable
but they gave up because pain-free Was
Out Of Reach
we have really good new information that
I'm going to share and so from now on I
want you to think about pain as a Venn
diagram with physiology fear and control
I'm going to tell you how each of these
can give you power over pain
right now I'm translating these in my
research into a low back pain device to
reduce opioid use
but 20 years ago
I just wanted to have a Fast cure for
needle pain for IV access and my kids
shots
I was driving home one night after a
graveyard shift and my hands were
vibrating on the steering wheel because
we needed to get the tires balanced I
was ignoring that to think about pain
and when I got home and reached for the
door of my house
my hand was numb
vibration
so I burst in My Boy Scout husband
grabbed some frozen peas and we had
ourselves a genuine Eureka moment where
cold and vibration blocked pain
over the next decade I found the right
frequency to block pain I got a grant
and I created Buzzy which is vibration
plus ice
in a b shape and you put it on your arm
when you're getting an injection and to
date 45 million needle procedures have
decreased pain and over 80 randomized
controlled trials independently all
around the world have been published
but
um at about 30 randomized controlled
trials in one of my colleagues came to
me and confided that he was in opioid
recovery and he asked whether or not
Buzzy could let him get through a total
knee replacement drug free
I'd never thought about it it's the same
pain nerve for knees as for needles so I
said maybe
and he did it
vibration Plus Cold replaced Oxycontin
so at that point I went all in to figure
out why
and here is what we know so the reason
that vibration decreases pain is because
the physiology of the nerves of
light touch pressure stretching and
motion all race pain to the spine now
people have tried electricity to trigger
the light touch nerves but we now know
that motion shown in green is what's
most effective at shutting the gate on
sharp pain
this is called gait control and the
exact right frequency of vibration
triggers the nerves that decrease pain
the physiology of ice is different
so the cold goes up to the brain where
the conductor goes
obnoxious but not dangerous I will
decrease Sensations coming from
everywhere and it decreases pain
everywhere
if a child was so freaked out from
previous experiences that even the swab
hurt
physiology wasn't as helpful so we added
distraction like a monkey poster and
what we discovered was combining
Counting plus making a decision cut pain
in half
so for example how many monkeys are
actually touching the bed
activates the decision switchboard
I know what you guys are doing all right
it's five
here is here is your pain hack for the
day though if you do not have monkeys on
hand then find any sentence and count
how many of the letters have holes in
them
counting deciding so like you got a g
hole o hole a oh
I guarantee you and your family will use
this
biggest tack though is though is
understanding why distraction works and
now through functional MRI we can
actually see pain happen and it's not
one place
pain is a symphony of connections from
the sensation area to the conductor to
the decision switchboard and then to
fear memory meaning control
so if the decision switchboard is
occupied sorting monkeys it can't notify
fear and meaning
and you feel less pain
what you feel
is mostly what you expect to feel
all right stay with me if you're a kid
the same punch hurts more from a bully
than from your buddy
and if you're an adult and you feel
something the second you think it's
cancer it hurts more and more until you
find out
it's not
and those same kids who had horrible
shot experiences can tolerate all kinds
of needle pain to look cool
because it is a different context
these patterns called connectums
are very personal because experiences
lay down more of the same sensation
and we now know that people who have
certain areas in the brain connected
feel more pain than people with
different areas connected
and more importantly untreated pain or
intense pain can lay down heavier
connections so that even when your body
is healed you will still feel more pain
it's this very plasticity and
personalization which makes the
physiology fear control Matrix so useful
because
choosing physiologic options that you
can layer that work for you decrease
pain like heat cold vibration deep
relaxation acupuncture capsaicin
exercise meditation
there's more Christopher probably had 10
of these around his house and just
didn't know it
having control over your options
decreases pain deep breathing increases
control choosing what to focus on
increases control
fear and control are the volume knobs
for pain
fear controls so many of our Sensations
this shouldn't be unusual but we don't
practice it for pain so if you're home
alone and you hear a clunk
your hearing becomes hypersensitive
but when you remember your kids home
from college
your fear dials down and your brain
overrides it and says don't worry about
it
Saint Augustine called Payne the
greatest of evil
the survival system it cannot be all
evil
so instead think of pain as you're
nagging
safety obsessed exaggerating friend
who's sometimes wrong
and it's okay to ignore or override your
friend if you know that you're safe
this takes practice
on a flight that was turbulent I had an
entire cup of scalding hot coffee dumped
straight on my ankle
electric jolt through my scalp I ripped
off my sock it was already red it was
going to blister there was no way I
could get my foot into that little sink
to get cold water on it and then I
remembered
physiology hack
I had an unopened cold beer
medical grade cold beer went on my ankle
stat
I had a vibrator in my carry-on because
I would on my ankle and then
the pain kind
and then my fear hack I'm like there's a
barf bag that has holy letters but I'm
gonna put it in the pocket pouch and
save it because then I have increased
control and pain MacGyver I was no
longer that concerned
although then I realized I'm that guy
with my bare foot sticking out in the
aisle on a plane
with a beer on it
power over pain isn't always pretty
but it is possible and it is absolutely
critical
because there's one more misconception
we have not talked about
I honestly thought that opioids turned
off some pain switch
they turn on our reward system
so some people feel amazing but most
people just still feel pain but don't
care
now this is a godsend for people with
chronic pain diseases we should not take
them away and in the trauma Bay the more
morphine the first 24 hours after a burn
or a wound the less post-traumatic
stress the less chronic pain later
but studies show that recovery after
surgery is just as well accomplished
with coaching and physiologic options
and if you're one of the people who feel
amazing with opioids it's too risky
a study in 2019 found that 1 in 15 young
adults who got opioids for their wisdom
tooth removal had substance use disorder
within a year
Ibuprofen works better
so so what do we do
well in my dream world we have Health
Care Systems pay for options and
coaching for Christophers everywhere and
we quit giving double-digit
prescriptions for opioids for home
recovery
in the real world 80 000 people died in
the U.S last year from opioid overdoses
and 80 percent of substance use
disorders starts with a pill prescribed
for pain
usually taken from your friend's
medicine cabinet
people can't afford options doctors 20
years later still don't know them
but you do
you all now know to throw away the
opioids in your medicine cabinet
you now know that there are options you
can use to decrease pain and you know
that pain-free should be ditched for
more comfortable
and whether you dump skeleton coffee or
pain wakes you and exhausts you every
day
options that are in your control
can allow you to reframe pain
thank you
wow Amy thank you like really thank you
it's amazing
um
so how do you think that pain scales
have set us back from this work that
you're doing and how is the NIH treating
pain and addiction differently now
so um one of the 120 versions of this
talk I I talked about
um how the thing is in the 90s if we
wanted to diseaseify pain it meant that
we had to be able to measure it and so
that was where the faces scales come
from and they're actually very useful in
the emergency department
um to tell whether or not a medicine is
working in fact we were one of the first
ones that showed the sickle cell that
the patients report based on the scales
was what was most indicative of whether
they needed to be admitted rather than
any biologic marker but what we're doing
now is we're using something called the
the promise scales so it's it's how
intense pain is on five-point scales how
much it interferes so there's pain
interference pain intensity and the way
we're looking at pain is much more on
the impact for the person rather than
trying to pretend there's any kind of
objective pain measurement okay and and
you mentioned that you're working on
some new applications for for Buzzy
specifically like for back pain what are
some of the the possibilities that we
have here for what what this could do
for us in the future yeah on my
Tombstone is going to be a vibrating bee
I'm trying to it's actually called Duo
Therm not Buzzy
um but but what we've learned is that
there are harmonics of interaction
between the specific frequencies that
cancel out the pain so there's one
particular nerve called the petinium
that has a very specific frequency range
and by causing them to interact we're
starting to explore more about the pain
that's coming from the fascia between
the skin and between the muscles but
that area is where where we're
unexplored and so by interacting with
different frequencies and then layering
heat or cold pressure
um options giving people the choice of
so many different ways to do it it's
really engaging all the different areas
of the brain from which pain comes wow
okay well thank you so much Amy welcome
thank you all